yeah i mean i'm just planning to put
like sound proof uh
panels on the wall and i'm just gonna
put that on the side walls
yeah you got your first noise complaint
didn't you i did get a noise complaint
yeah after all this time i know
i was definitely pushing it to be fair i
think because you know when i first
moved in
i like we wouldn't even like walk at
full speed around the house
because i'd heard how how careful i had
to be yeah and then i realized oh
nothing's happening
oh so i start walking normally you know
so you kept testing the limit
and then and then the apex stream starts
getting later and later
apex at two am streams did the push it
over the limit i don't know what it was
that did it because when i got the
complaint i hadn't done any late night
streams that i would say were loud like
i think they had only done one
and it was very very quiet one i know it
was because i was just talking
so i wondered what did it because there
was somewhere else full on shouting at
like 2 a.m
yeah and i didn't get it so i mean we
got a noise complaining at our place but
a week speed run yeah but a week after
the actual event that it happened so i'm
just like
why am i getting the complaint now after
a week i think if it goes to the agency
then the agency tells you right
but the agency like has my number on
speed dial so it's like they could
easily have just like
called me the next morning being like uh
were you laughing like yeah we got a
snitch bro it's kind of cringe
no no because we got you bro don't worry
about
legit i was like who said it
i was literally like leaving i'm like
who's saying
they won't tell you like i i understand
privacy reasons but also
i'd like to know so that i can kind of
like maybe put some stuff on that right
right
because like if i know who it is at
least because they didn't even tell me
if it was like someone from tell me
who's a little [ __ ] so i can
soundproof that sound no because like if
i knew it was like say the neighbors
downstairs then i could be like oh okay
maybe i should you know do some padding
on the floor or something like that or
like thick ass carpet or something to
avoid it or if it's like
people across the road well then it's
like well i can't do [ __ ] anything
about that so yeah
like if i knew who the neighbor was then
i could you know
take precautions and you know work so
that i don't have to you know i almost
understand that like if it was
me complaining i probably wouldn't want
to be named but also you could maybe
i don't need to know the specific person
i just need to know if it's like is it a
neighbor below me
is it someone across the road is it in
this building i don't know i guess
they're worried about you might go to
him be like yo
open the [ __ ] why are you complaining
little [ __ ] why are you complaining
to my face [ __ ] but then also
you could be like hey man um
could i ask like when you need me to be
quiet yeah you know is there like stuff
going because like you know
if my neighbors do they can shout all
they [ __ ] want yeah
i i i don't give a [ __ ] yeah but you
know if i was
you know if i had a kid or something
then maybe you know i'd be like hey keep
it down after 10. you know that's the
problem it's like
yeah because if that was me and i was
getting noise complaints from say
someone from upstairs
i just [ __ ] got up to them being like
hey i'm not like gonna snitch on you or
something like can can we just like talk
it out so that we can come to some kind
of mutual agreement but yeah in japan
no one [ __ ] does that yeah they just
like ring ring help me please
but but i asked i asked like what can
they do like what can they do with this
complaint what happens they were like
they can like technically get you
evicted if they like tried really
freaking hard especially if you're a
foreigner
because i mean you know like that from
my last place that woman downstairs
tried to do that
i'm like how [ __ ] hard do they have
to try to get me evicted though like i
said like how much effort does it have
to go through and i think they said it
was like it was like a lot of work and
it probably wouldn't happen so i was
like
well i'm not i'm not that bad i'm not
shouting all the time
redemption in this [ __ ] waiting for the
lightning to strike
but i think i've done like they clearly
don't care during the day because i've
done like voice lines during the day
where i'm full on screaming yeah
they're not okay during the day it's
only a night i bet some neighbors do
care during the day they're like
i mean yeah
i just thought someone was getting
murdered